yay-hey no way - welcome to this video
playing as aircon master Sirkin no it's
from Tokyo right yep so we've got a
scotch opening I'm sticking to my to my
guns here the special befallen line
surely served me quite well yeah another
five is what they usually do not sure
about this Bishop c4 I don't think it's
that critical you can maybe take on c6
plenty five but yeah well I it's not a
move 95 already looks pretty weird so I
at least get your half a special pair so
this and night 64 is that possible I
mean I will be better even after just
cancelling of course but if I can win
the pawn Knight f5 I got d5 don't
believe that this should work out for
white
okay so that's just castle and so we
wonder big center pond and got the
bishop pair that's good black after 11
moves
so okay
I got a somewhat distracting message
sorry really don't know um yeah I keep I
need to develop in a pneumonias way and
I wasn't totally sure what to do with
the center but this looks okay to me now
the bishop on e6 is nicely positioned
and I have deform at the right moment
now maybe not sure yeah I can still
improve the piece placement a little bit
it's no need to write things look FD age
then maybe default push the center I
also have Bishop takes h3 as a
short-term threat watch out man like a1
mover and basically but it's part of it
okay isn't no that is a threat no that
much let's just go here
yeah I mean it's a very nice position
the night only five isn't really stable
it's not protected him just once by the
rook yeah so maybe annoyed the Queen and
then pushed before
not really sure but I think I should
push the point at some point
get this get the center rolling forward
okay so here
yeah maybe just take him it's easy easy
easy move now the Queen has such high
again and rook e8 enter bishop c7 now
next I guess attack the knight doesn't
have good squares Knight g4 maybe M in
energy form
I was
maybe just this pinning the bishop
I could still Quint xb7 it was maybe
still possible I don't know anyway let's
prevent it
yeah yeah yeah I'm on that on a form
effect go go g5 is there anything good
97 maybe that's still checking for has
to go to see one probably but then
whoops rupee aid was the idea
it's not changing anything if I just
drop it back no Bishop c1 I can just
take only father he just queen f4 I
think what he was losing material anyhow
I couldn't couldn't prevent it anymore I
was too too much pressure simply at his
that's how I'm how I thought it was yeah
when yeah Queen ef3 is an extremely bad
move which is basically that that almost
losers I think completely forced now
takes takes yeah and I grab before I
didn't see why not really of course I
can just Castle and I'm clearly better
there's g5 coming something like that
without grabbing the pawn is also
terrible I get to get the total but
should pan and yeah but but why not grab
this this was not possible due to d5
with this visit it's essentially a
double attack and after castles I mean I
just I just keep the pawn I should have
played c5 immediately it was a bit silly
to play c6 first but again I was a bit
distracted I think here it's it's nice
oh I missed the tactic Bishop h6 oh nice
that's the idea and White has escaped
with a draw
Wow okay so we should play whatever
rookie agent hmm came yeah it's a very
convenient position really the whole
time yeah he could have taken on b7 I
was just not really focused enough that
was possible now that's also the same
Bishop f5 is so better for black but I
didn't did I didn't see but after a
three I think I mean I'm in control
again yes if I should go Bishop c1 I
mean it's better for black but but yeah
I hear I'm winning now a Bishop III
blunder c5 Bishop d2 is hanging and
Bishop c1 I simply take because I always
have this at the end so I will win the
bishop also after Queen takes and the
trade and they win the bishop again so
this was basically due to the opening
yeah Queen eeeh three years some yeah
just stepping into into a big fork not a
good move at all yeah thanks a lot for
watching